bro the last thing i linked was giving
me head while messaging her man
multitasking at its finest
oh i missed that part
dms
dating apps i don't have time for that
i don't believe you should kiss a lot of
frogs to find your prince i believe in
grilling them i'm gonna be going on a
series of dates to find who can really
wow me
this is thrilling
one one it's a one too funny you're
getting me six foot five somewhat
humorous and yeah when it's here today
you get me a little bit and now we're
gonna see how it goes still
oh yeah man's ready for grilling store
trust me i came prepared
nope man's not nervous one bit you get
me confidence levels
up here everybody fans
ready you get me yeah let's get started
hi you're right yeah what's your name
anyone what's your like government
government name wow rudy escalating like
that that's crazy obviously as we
progress through the day you can ask
your name yeah no not just now right now
do you wanna know my name yeah
cheyenne that's a very nice name she's
lovely still she's sophisticated she's
very mature you know i mean she's
chilling and still i like him and she's
they're very aesthetically pleasing i
must say so you know i mean everything's
going great mate yeah i mean thank you
not sure though what was in like
abbreviation because i'm quite confident
do you not think no you are still like
you came with a suit and that you're
looking very you know
you know yeah you're looking nice
actually well cheers to that you're not
in a track suit that's what i'm saying
i started doing it the my name came in i
oh my god there's a guy that's not in a
tracksuit i feel like he needs to win
how tall are you six foot five
bit of you
yes that's right i'm five five i
a whole subway difference yeah a whole
subway that's crazy that's crazy so
would you say you're like really funny i
wouldn't say i'm funny i'd say i'm
hilarious um make me laugh then maybe
make you laugh
wow you put me on the spot there still
isn't that funny then you can't just say
like
it don't make me laugh in that light did
you get it you got warm into it you know
i mean he said he's funny why is he not
making me laugh most like the wildest
thing you've done
in terms of what in one cup
take it any way you want
what's actually wow i see i knew it was
coming still see i knew this one was
coming and that you see i was sussing
around and and that you get me
trying to ask me about jeans and them
things there so you get i just had to
err
and slow down you get what i'm trying to
say about hey so i'm saying she's going
to wait to the later dates if you want
to know more information you get
oh flipping it i don't even know now
what about you you you answered a
question for us what do i do for fans
yeah when you ask my question i realize
i'm not that fun i'm quite a homebody i
like to chill
spend time with my friends and just hang
out at home we'll go on like an activity
date soon okay where are you taking me
we'll go to the alps snowboarding would
you take a date somewhere like that or
you're just lying no no i'm not even
lying i really would um so where's the
best place you've taken the date uh
i was in a relationship dubai but that
wasn't really a date that i was in a
relationship yeah so that's not that
wild though that's a holiday no i know
but it's like what you've done on the
trying to holidays
on the dirt back in there and
swam with dolphins that was crazy still
nice why are you here today do you know
what i'm just trying to find a nice guy
also no a serious guy that knows how to
handle women you might have found the
man you're looking for gentlemen yeah
that's that confident pinky finger up oh
that's confidence there
tell me more about yourself though i
want to hear about you what would you
want to know what's your type
you know what i hate that question
because it sounds so like cliche but my
type is actually funny that's what i was
like oh wow yeah what happens is funny
happens to be in my name cool
yeah but you've actually got to be funny
though wow that's crazy though as i said
as we progress up you know yeah
i'll expose more of my um hilarious side
right now it's just a bit reserved you
know what i mean i like substance as
well i feel like you can be funny and
you can have the chat but if you've got
nothing to offer
then it's a completely waste of time
like you need to have a brain you know
exactly that's true and funny enough i'm
actually quite brainy i would try and
say that yeah yeah i've done mechanical
engineering before that comedy i wanted
to do i wanted to be like f1 and that
really was hamlet and all the things
there yeah that's interesting what would
you say is the best thing you offer a
woman security
affection
joy
what do you bring to the table i bring a
lot actually i think i bring a lot of
compassion i love honesty because i feel
like people will miss that out and i
feel like that's a big thing also
communication that's key stuff yes i'd
say like they're the main things that i
would lead with but i also just bring
myself and it's not as in like this city
girl lifestyle where it's like i do this
and i do that like
i'm so happy you said that still happy
though no i am trust me smile on the
inside yeah i'm swimming on the inside
what's the red flag for you
what you just said actually so kind of
like seagull movements yeah i mean like
immaturely describe to me what a city
girl is to you
i would say a sea girl yeah it's just
like a girl that does anything for money
that will lack yeah that's not like it's
not not a work ethic no but i'm saying
anything for money they don't want to
work like they just want to go out
finesse and sell themselves you know
what i mean that's the secret bring any
girl around me yeah but just not a sea
girlfriend man don't do all of this
flipping
working bags and all of that nonsense
yeah yeah you lost can get that once
married you're getting like man all of
that stuff you get me not now everybody
loves finesses judging from your well
firstly i'd like to say that you're very
aesthetically pleasing um
yeah you don't like a seagull you look
very sophisticated so thank you
so what's your thoughts on
women that do have sex and money and
stuff like that well that's darting in
it like no i'm not bashing them you get
me like you gotta make your bread and
that but
that's your thing still not writing it
but like
do you rate hustle though
yeah yeah but there's a big difference
between hustling and prostitution from
me personally
that's just that's just yeah yeah yeah
you gotta just
yeah yeah you get me you're doing your
thing but
i don't really you know i mean so what's
your thoughts on the double standards in
society so because you don't like the
city girl lifestyle but
you know men like to glorify that
they're trapping and stuff like that
what's your thoughts on that well that's
what
it's it's life but that's what i'm
trying to say like you see the actual
city girls like like
regardless of what they're doing
remember it's like what they're doing is
in the music side because they're just
talking about what like they do on a
day-to-day business and that's what i'm
saying though so like income it's the
same with traffic and all of them things
they're in it's like it's a
you've got to do what you got to do in
the situation you can't not write one
and then be like oh actually it's fine
they're trappers they're doing their
thing so what about a woman that has no
other option but to do something like
but there's something wrong with that do
you not think that's a double standard
because it's worse i think as well
sometimes when it comes to the trapped
lifestyle and things like that like
there's a lot more lives ruined so
that's why i feel like if you're gonna
have an attitude about one then you need
to have it for both or just be
completely like zen lifestyle and not be
bothered i said i don't rate what they'd
like to finish and all of that yeah but
regardless it's still there singing in
it same way that i read the mandarin
that's rapping about trapping that's
rapping about day-to-day life even if
it's bad and violent
once they skyrocket and they start to do
their thing and that i still rate the
same way what we're trying to eat
before here i had that caribbean
remember i told you i was gonna have
caribbean did you eat meat got you meat
yeah no homo what do you mean no that
just sounds a bit funny still what do
you eat mate no yeah the wheat nook is
like what like the way you're squinting
at me and that you're very kind of like
saying a different type of concept what
context
you're trying to do
no yeah i eat meat though yeah sexually
would you say you eat per se
the woman i'm married that i get on one
knee to you that's the only woman i'm
working have you done it before yeah
i've done it before because i was in
really lazy you're not married to i
before i was going to be married to the
woman
that was very close to marrying her so
you've only done it once in your life
what are you talking about acting one
single time all with one person yeah one
single time no obviously i've done it
more than one time in it but i was in a
long-term relationship but until now the
woman that marries marriage until the
day that man gets on one knee and really
slides that ring on then that yeah
that's enough why is it such an issue
why why do why does everyone get so mad
at that question no it's not even mad
it's just preference isn't it like
for me
why does everyone get triggered by it oh
i'm not triggered i'm perfectly calm
right really yeah
i'm fantastic you know what i mean
obviously she's asking man if man eats
the nanilans and that but obviously you
get me like you gotta wait till marriage
i'm trying to say these girls and that
they're all thinking all these men what
man's gonna be out here just yo yo yo
man he's [ __ ] in that no
go away talk marriage one knee i feel
like it's a lot of things like man don't
do like yeah there's such a taboo
subject like i meant to talk about it
because it's like culturally this and
that like you know you know
yeah exactly i haven't got my woman yet
so who am i pleasing but do you like
your dick sucks oh yeah yeah exactly so
you probably like yours but for to do it
to women it's an issue yeah but i'm not
forcing anyone to to suck my ding-a-ling
you get me so if a girl says to me yeah
oh i'm not gonna i'm not gonna suck your
willy and that yeah because you're not
gonna work at man i'll be like cool no
i'm not pressed yeah then no one has sex
it's just a sexless marriage because
we're both being petty oh no no i'm not
my marriage i'm just talking about like
right now like if i was just out in that
box when it comes to marriage oh yeah
obviously all the floodgates are opening
that you get me but until then
no that's something special that you you
know i mean that's for your mistakes you
get me okay
yeah so do you stop late man
they look like a suck dick
um
yeah yeah you do still like do you know
right now yeah like this is a compliment
by the way you know like one of them
that is not a compliment saying to
someone you look like something let me
land i didn't even finish hold on like
what you look like right now is one of
them like one of them like sexy like
teacher porn stars and that you know you
know then one's there and then they were
like oh my god
where's your homework you know then
what's that no percy that's [ __ ] up
wait wait wait hold on a minute
in what weird universe is it where
saying to someone you look like you suck
dick as a compliment i'm sorry men that
is not a compliment i don't i don't like
it when people watch porn i find it so
good no i don't watch one there you just
gave me a
what's going on obviously i've watched
porn in it but i don't watch porn
so that's why i'm supposed to take you
saying i look like i suck dick as a
compliment no no no no because it's just
like right now yeah you look like you're
like one of them teachers you know you
could just say i look nice instead of
also like you look like one of them like
in one of them role play things and then
you're like you know what i mean
teachers and that where's your homework
oh my god how are you going to pay me
like what i'm saying
if you're out
is it do women come on the table is it
like yeah get the girls
any older women like selective women
yeah i'll let you on my table hundred
million that's nice yeah would you like
me on your table don't i
no i'm joking i don't approach people's
tables ladder do you not yeah i can't do
that i was just testing you
well it's nice and wait no wait what did
you say yes or no i said i don't know
yet i'm like if i'm out with the girls
i'm like the girls no one's coming
around our table
yeah i'm that friend that will cockblock
everyone because wow we're not here
trying to get man tonight wow so you
just dare to shake wonder have a great
time yeah i don't really shake my arse
in clubs why not i guess i just don't
like that kind of attention
i rate that have you ever liked to have
sex
um yes
oh actually yeah when i was young yeah
because obviously i look like i look a
bit older than my actual age and
especially when i was mad young
once i lied about my agent to here you
know i mean harold was the female
26. how old was he
18. how old did you say he was i said i
was like what i almost said i was like i
rounded it up to the nearest decimal
point so i said i was like 25 something
like that how do i how the hell can you
go like 18 to 25. because like did you
get me like i was tall this and that you
know i mean yeah but you need to have a
level of maturity to like you're a woman
yeah i know but that's what i'm saying
would you not say i'm at all so was you
successful oh yeah obviously yeah have
you ever cheated never in my life never
cheated never i've been to you though
but i never cheated speak stone but yes
but [ __ ] with mandem are you rated or
not are you that friend that's like god
did the shop run
just curious i've never read the shots
for nobody still yeah i'd say i'm rated
still
he definitely thinks he's the man i
don't put myself any higher than all
that any of my my guys in that you know
i mean there's no ego no there's no ego
all of my team got a win yeah i mean
like if we're walking together down the
street
like a stranger shouldn't be able to
tell oh this is the boss or this is the
guy you get we should all look like a
guy no matter if
one's famous one ain't famous one's got
biscuits yeah power rangers
would you say you're emotionally
available
what do you mean emotionally available
firstly are you in tune with your
emotions
are you a good communicator of how you
feel or do you bottle it up i think i'd
like to say i am but i don't know
sometimes i keep stuff in there yeah but
that's the problem like that's why i
need you to solve my problem you need me
yeah that's what i'm trying to say am i
your mom
whoa no
oh cool blimey mate
do you
uh yeah hundred million percent yeah you
can't go on wife one girl that's just
been that's called bare unnecessarily
like
high ass my allergen that nice what's
like mad body cat and why i don't get
why it's an issue no it's an issue fam
it's definitely an issue like you can't
what so you're telling me that man is
gonna go wife one girl that's got like
that's beat over like 500 men and that
no
it's better what if you had sex with
like 500 women that's a stretch i will
never have six or 500 women okay as long
as you keep the standard for yourself
then yeah obviously it's not an issue
energy sharing that's real i don't know
that's dead you drop the energy so you
know that's what i'm trying to see
what's the point for that extra point
yeah you know about energy exchange oh i
can see your demeanor change when um i
said that word so yeah that's a good
point yeah all right
yeah 100 percent
definitely are you though yeah i am 100
what's family time to you spending time
with them spending time on brother mom
and dad
you know i mean go get something to eat
and that uh take my brother out or
cinema something i mean i'm the older
sibling that's it okay so you've got the
responsibility yeah do you want kids how
many kids do you want i only want one
child you want one child yeah why
because basically yeah cause i'm the
older sibling yeah like and my brother's
what how old is this guy again
that 12. did you just say you're a
family man you don't know how old your
brother is no i always get food i always
know no no no no no no it's always
better confusing than that yeah i mean
because look he's 12 years old and he's
nearly six foot with size nine feet like
growing exactly so it's kind of hard
sometimes i think he's older than man
he's got a little bit of like special
needs in it yeah i mean yeah so like
i've basically had to be like a parent
the third parent like from like from the
day he was born in it so i've had to be
very mature and like wipe his arse and
that
burp him and that so you i already feel
like i've had a huge you know what i
mean
so it's like i need to enjoy my life
endeavor you're ready so what you're
going to have like hot boy summer uh you
want to enjoy life
definitely not what i said oh but
actually why am i capping boy now i'm
having a hot boy summer replay oh yeah
yeah i'm out here boy when i say i was
out here yeah okay let me let me define
you you were doing really well until
then no but when i say out here i don't
mean like that doesn't have to mean me
going and just whacking their bbl use i
mean flying out going l.a going cyprus
this and that enjoying my life do you
know what i mean like what's your body
count my body count whoa every verse
fam do you think i'm telling
any girl on the first date my body count
relay
dummy stupid
that's a lot no it's not a lot it's just
if you want to know that that's for the
second day you get me
that's a yes and no yeah same obviously
let's say like you was in a relationship
and that yeah
and then there's one girl that's just
burning up our backs and that
that nine increases right up in your
face and that man's lacking that
obviously that's you get me that's just
that you are boundaries but if it's like
your brethren and it's like the picture
isn't mad like a decent exposure and
it's just like you're supporting their
thing yeah it's called you know i mean
if i'm with a guy and then he's liking a
woman's only like a picture then you're
gonna just go wow i'm supporting her
only fans in it like nah but that's a
stress that's what i mean that's out of
line
why would you need to like only friends
do you subscribe to anyone first no
rate my thing bro i said
bro do i even know i've never even been
on that website then i found that's
weird that's for them and their
subscriptions and that
like have you ever done anything that's
toxic have you ever been oh okay cool
like when i was younger that yeah man
it's like when is that caught brain and
that all that done my thing and that and
then just boom that
like just feel selfish just s out no i'm
not selfish because i don't do that
often when i was young
you're mature and now you're growing
yeah don't get [ __ ]
well so you got blood dropping bounce no
old days that was all these yeah no one
ever takes accountability for their [ __ ]
like i will hold myself accountable and
it's been like i don't like the crazy
psycho girl label because i feel like
too many people glamorize that but
you genuinely madame are so
well
mannered and behaved i love that i love
that your mindset is amazing now i can't
add uh the mindset is making sense still
she's got moles she's got a business
mindset very mature she's sensible
like everything's making sense i won't
even lie like that's one good thing i
can definitely say that she got head
screwed on well no one's just psycho for
no reason like do you have a psycho x uh
yeah yeah yeah 100 million percent like
would she come for me if i dated you oh
yeah actually you know what's mad yeah
psycho what did you do to make her
psycho not in bruv she's just tapped
listen there's no such thing as a crazy
ex without you taking accountability
he's definitely done something to make
her crazy yeah that's just tapped for no
reason i don't know this girl was just
saying about the whole accountability
thing no no no no no one's tapped for no
reason no but it's not even man it's
like
there's been things that lack so have
you done things to get her to this point
where she's now moving man no like it's
things she's
been through all that do you know
yeah did you get like i don't have time
for that yeah i mean i'm too genuine
like and i just want to treat my missus
good do that i mean bake off and that
being bora bora and that you're getting
me pina coladas and that you're getting
me there i'm just chilling i just want
to have a good life i don't really have
time to be a [ __ ]
yeah that's man
yeah
[Music]
can i see it huh
[Music]
to be honest mike can back it out right
now but you've got there's like there's
the one savage chat and there's always
one calm one yes you look like
then i do that
where you can see everything
like look look
uh
you can see like
sorry no yeah
yeah
okay look just read that in it
i don't think that's that bad what
what does it say you should be gone read
out bro the last thing i linked was
giving me head while messaging her man
multitasking at its finest
oh i missed that part is this how your
friends are moving no this is guilty by
association now you know
yeah that's kind of bad still when she
was reading the message i blatantly
didn't even read it but i just said yeah
yeah i was thinking yeah she can just
read that it's all seen brain and that
head and that
man
that's definitely not me i don't even
say law yeah no you didn't i imagine you
use that guy in it your friends are
moving mad though yeah so is she what
did you say to your friend then i just
was that brother
you got other you're holding that man go
deal with them what
first thing you can't call women hoes no
i'm not calling women who's i'm calling
the hozos no but what's a hoe a hoe is a
female that sleeps around with
several men
simultaneously and uh finesses it kind
of ties into being is her body her
choice but then men can do it
yeah i know because you're a friend it's
a male friend yeah yes if your friends
are like that the apple doesn't fall far
from the tree
he can do that because he's got more
time on his hands than andy
i genuinely don't have the time to be
doing all of them things they're like
that's wrong and i always think about
like what i just said imagine if you was
the guy in that that's just a long day
for you boy yeah i mean so you said that
to him yeah i said that to him i know
even g check the gal is off him i was
like bloody you got a man from no no
yeah
it's all complicated in that right
[ __ ] moves down there you go no
one million percent yeah
absolutely bang on because men say a lot
about that but then if you look at all
the girls they like on instagram
they are
the instagram models
that was a generic statement secondly um
from instagram alone um
of course even instagram being an
algorithm that has it's always going to
put out those women with bbl and the
perfect figures and this and that and
thirdly
you can't tell somebody personally from
instagram so that's why men is just
going to be like oh what big backs
double tap that
big boobs double tap that you get me so
that's how you move nope
yeah you you're quite confident the
reason why i don't like up bear peoples
and especially gals photo yeah because
everybody else can see that you liked it
that's embarrassing like you know i mean
like i've got standard boy
you've got obviously personalities
number one you've got to have a great
personality good morals family person
mature
business mindset and
you gotta be godly
appearance wise now so you just gotta
have
pretty face slim waist and a big backs
it's hard to find just normal people
that have normal moles and just you know
because everyone's done at it
exactly that's what i'm trying to say so
what's your preference um personally
because you want to grow out of them
exactly because the looks are going to
fade away you know i mean that's why i
always say like it's like i always even
told them man it's like oh that oh
you've all had the penis gal in that
butt oh that's dead personalities you
get so don't matter that i don't care
about penguins no more like i really
don't the personality's gotta be
it's got a one shot i mean
what's your toxic trait what do you mean
like elaborate i would say your toxic
trait is not letting people in
because you're quite guarded from your
past experiences i wouldn't say that's
toxic i would say that's just
like
like a like a protection that sort of
barrier you know i mean
going to come up
but it's just me sussing you out first
understanding how you think your mindset
your morals and then yeah you can
proceed because man's not just going to
be like oh yeah yeah yeah you got blacks
in that coming to my old and then boom
you just come out and mess up their ass
glasses nah
that's not happening you can only
protect yourself for for so long i get
it but there's times where you could
just be so in your ptsd like you're
going to miss out on so many
opportunities with your life that's you
know but i wouldn't say i'm that mad
into my ptsd like i'm still very relaxed
and chilled like i don't know
but i know you're saying that but for
example like if you've had someone
cheating on your past so then your
attitude with me if i'm going out and
i'm wearing something skimpy or you know
skin like oh that's mine you might start
being a bit like because you're ptsd no
like you could look at penguins whatever
where whatever you want as long as
you're stepping out with me
but what if like i was just wearing
something i want to go out with the
girls good
i trust you like you took my
relationship
you represent man i represent you if
you're going out looking peng damn right
you're getting right
yeah it's calm obviously as long as
you're not entertaining mandem wherever
you're going and that that's going to
come up because you know man i'm going
to be like yo are you missing that
caramel sundae
you get me but as long as you're doing
anything have fun and that you get me
and you come back home yeah that's true
yeah i ain't insecure like that like you
can do your thing so would you say
you've got big dick energy uh yeah like
you could say that oh big dick as well
yeah yeah i've got size 13 feet so this
means that's a big thing
yeah but obviously you know the
what
yeah yeah
i'm a ninja but also let me just throw
that in
what would you do if i have slept with
two of your friends in the past yeah
your untouchable store do you like anime
nope
it's not happening bro it's just not
happening that you've already been
touched by my brothers my my brothers
it's not happening bro
really no why because you slept with two
man legends but what if we're really in
love
in love we're out of love
two member two not one not two but it's
amazon nah they're gonna be number three
huh me number three yeah love no that's
not happening
what would you do if i didn't want to
sleep with you for the first six months
of our relationship
um
why would you want to sleep with me for
the first six months like you said
you're like it's like a big commitment
and it's a big deal and i think
firstly energy exchange as well yeah and
i
really pride myself with who i am as a
person
so i would feel disrespected if i step
with you at so easy in the sense that
it's just
i'm a big deal to me
so why should i give you myself so
freely that's actually yeah in fact the
man actually agrees with that story i
can't even lie i'm not even becoming a
stunt because it's true that that needs
to smash by what six months boy oh boy
blood let me just hydrate myself
and as well like when you're dating
someone like it takes a while before you
even exclusive so i'd rather just make
that decision take the time before
really realizing like actually he's a
nice guy i will sleep with him or
whatever because i think you could be
dating multiple women be having sex with
them
like energy exchanges things you want to
sleep with her monday sleep with me on
tuesday or whatever i like you craig
david no i had to marry in it
yeah i don't have attention there you go
that's another one trust me the vibes
there the vibes there so i'm not saying
i'm a complete angel but
with my intention when i'm dating it's
for marriage and that oh what's the
point that bear man just be dating for
no reason and that just allowing bare
people to say yeah
he's my accent yeah no i did what would
you do if i wanted to involve other
people in our sex life you know swinging
prisons
i will put this out there that's never
had a threesome would you want one or
not definitely see that mine's on that
store yeah why would you like one
because it's like why not like just
freeze somebody has never done it in it
so it's like yeah yeah yeah two gallon
that
yeah i mean me in the middle engine and
run that little you know i mean yeah
what did you say me in the middle
meeting a little nope
did
yeah it made me feel like accomplished
like yeah it might have to freeze some
of that i want to see like it's not a
conversion line yeah but it would just
make me feel like yeah yeah taking that
it's just one of them things as a guy
it's like you want you want to just
experience it like yeah i mean someone
cheated would you ever take them back no
my [ __ ] blood i'm not knowing that
sorry am i a big kid blood
that's amazing but what if it was like
we were
going in 10 years of a marriage
no no really no but you don't think
sometimes marriage could be like a like
there's a compromise where you think you
know what done up partnership like jay-z
and beyonce but you can help me find the
tosses that i give no
no i don't care do you have any fetishes
man like strong coughs in there oh
that's me gone
oh sweat don't worry you can go gym in
there okay
i'll be your pt but yeah i like cars
that you see when you're like you see
you're wearing hills now yeah and then
like the girls are walking and that yeah
and then the cars are just like that
impression of a woman no i just walked
the strut and then that yeah and the
cops are bad just doing
that
who's been your best date
oh it's difficult because i kind of feel
like
each date gave me something different
that was a very political answer
and it's between two people
chris
because he gave me the substance but
then so did ty
oh okay so it's between them too
how do i compare
yeah you're doing it right i'm doing all
right yeah um because you know what is
mine's not giving you
and it's not giving you the whole
package just yet because i've got to
save that for the next date what do you
think i'm going to rate you out of 10
today
i'd like to see like
a strong 8.6 reoccurring isn't it right
so what's that what's the verdict
not giving it to you oh you're not going
to tell me no you're going to save that
for the next day as well
oh the next day yeah okay
you know what mate i think the date was
fantastic you know what i mean um got
good gist of her you know i mean um got
a good mindset on her got a good pair of
um
brain cells
he takes a lot of boxes and he was like
what six foot five yeah i think she lets
me stop yeah i think i think i'm gonna
see him again looking forward to the
second date not gonna lie to you he
dressed well
he's tall
he had good chat he had a very good
balance however he didn't make me laugh
as much as i wanted i'd say she'd give
me 8.6 recurring but you know i mean
let's give or take like
0.7 of a decimal so
you know above or below but yeah that
should be calm still
he thinks he's going to get an 8.6
did i
about that one
obviously if you don't like man now then
you get me then it's just burning that
girl you get me ruby man's got bear
yelling at her every rascal anyway yeah
you get me
i'm not even trying to play mind games i
think i'm gonna give him
an 8.5
not six
you